quand vous ouvrez votre grand
dictionnaire à la lettre r au dessus du
portrait de madame récamier par david
vous voyez images d'une grande vedette
de la télévision française
le petit train et nous sommes venus
rendre visite aujourd'hui au père du
plus célèbre des interludes maurice
prenant maurice bruno avant de jouer au
petit train dans la vie que faisiez-vous
entre les repas je t'ai sculpteur et de
la sculpture
j'étais au dessin et du dessin j'ai fait
de la halle est née générique des effets
spéciaux enfin je suis rentré dans le
cinéma par le par les trucages j'ai fait
des films documentaires de défis
techniques et puis
finalement un bon jour majorité des
petits trains mais ce petit train vous
l'avez fabriquer de vos mains oui ici
entièrement alain saulnier ils sont nés
ici là avec d&co mondiale avait des
décors avec du papier rocher enfin avec
tous des matériels comme on a pour faire
des effets spéciaux génériques les
maquettes les décors enfin tout tout a
été fait ici et vous l'avez présenter
immédiatement oui j'étais le compte est
mon ami pierre sabbagh et qu'il l'a
présenté à la direction au service de la
programmation jamais monsieur jacques
blanchet qui s'est intéressé à la
question et qui m'a qui a été vraiment
un très bon avocat pour moi et au cours
de la première période
le petit rang était consacrée à des
rébus et ça et ensuite vous en avez fait
le jeu de mémoire pour moi c'est ça
parce que d'abord
j'ai fait quarante films c'est déjà pas
mal pour avec la même formule j'ai voulu
changer de formule et puis en même temps
le rendre internationale c'est ça la
forêt faire des rébus japonais on
n'achète pas très bon et jusqu'à ce jour
vous allez tourner combien de finale
alors j'ai tourné le 40 films avec
les red bull x prince et 52 le film avec
le plus fort la mémoire 80 92 92 je vais
vous demander de nous dévoiler un secret
voilà nous avons su beaucoup de lettres
de téléspectateurs qui nous posent tous
d'ailleurs la bonne question
comment faites vous évoluez le petit
train dans la nature je pars avec tout
mon matériel évidemment et avec ma femme
est
nous cherchons de très beaux décors non
nous les poils français en a
vous allez peut-être sourire et pourtant
j'ai pas honte de le dire mais il a
fallu que je fasse le pitre un interlude
pour découvrir la france passait du
temps ces détails et si je suis heureux
personnellement qu'il y ait des
autoroutes
et bien c'est pour pouvoir apprécier
davantage la tranquillité des voies
secondaires dans lesquels on peut rouler
plus lentement
ça vous permet de chercher le décor on
est souvent seul sur la route ou dans la
nature mais quand on l'entend
surtout quand on commence à s'installer
parce que même dans un endroit
complètement perdu on a toujours des
visites
il ya aussi les jours noirs la pluie les
cabris du soleil ça tout le monde le
fait le vent en levant le vent qui un
jour a provoqué la chute du petit train
et de toute installation dans un ravin
de 200 mètres de profondeur aux gorges
de l'aude je croyais que tout était
perdu
on a passé cinq heures pour retrouver
toutes les pièces et on est trois jours
de réparation et ce qui a été le plus
terrible pour moi c'est que pendant ces
droits jour là où je n'ai pu tourner il
a fait un temps magnifique mais vous ne
m'avez toujours pas dévoiler votre petit
secret et bien c'est un accord de
perspectives
c'est très facile à voir d'ailleurs et
est ce que ce petit train donnera des
enfants il y a actuellement une maison
très importante qui fabrique en
miniature le petit train interlude dans
quelques semaines tout le monde pourra
se procurer d'ailleurs et il a été
exécuté avec une telle précision que
l'on peut vraiment l'appeler le bébé
interlude j'ai possédé un des prototypes
que j'utilisais au cours de mon dernier
voyage
ainsi on pourra voir le petit bébé
interlude faire ses premiers pas avec
son père sur les bords de la loire
d'autre part la petite comme motif
servira désormais dans le générique 1
située sur la france la région où le
film aurait été tournée parce que il ya
beaucoup de téléspectateurs qui vont
intégrer ce sujet là et qui voulait
connaître les endroits mais région filmé
avec le petit train
j'espère que de cette façon au pouvoir
le rpt donné en partie satisfaction mais
avec des succès qu'il a remportée
télévision française et même à
l'étranger
quel est son avenir bien mon avenir
j'aimerais pouvoir tourner en couleurs
parce que souvent je regrette parce que
j'arrive dans les décors extraordinaires
comme dans les gorges du verdon par
exemple si je tourne en couleur ça
serait vraiment formidable et je
voudrais tout menton en cô